[Musique]
bienvenue Philippe Benassaya bonjour
Patrice on va parler de politique
parce que d'abord vous êtes vous êtes un
homme politique vous avez été député
vous avez été maire de Bois-d'Arcy vous
êtes conseiller départemental
vice-président du conseil départemental
et là votre actualité c'est que vous
présentez à la présidence de la
fédération LRD des Yvelines qui est une
grosse fédération l'élection aura lieu
le 26 novembre vous lancer votre
campagne jeudi et le saint que le 5
octobre
c'est Pierre Bédier qui préside
jusqu'ici la fédération qui a décidé de
laisser sa place alors voilà l'élection
aurait dû donc le 26 novembre et vous
serez deux candidats a priori vraiment
et puis
Othman Nasro qui avait déjà déclaré sa
candidature qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
vous sépare au fond l'un de l'autre
alors d'abord j'avais pierre Bellier
m'avait informé il déjà des mois et des
mois qui ne qui l'arrêtaient
la présidence des républicains 78 et je
lui avais dit si c'est dans ce cas-là si
tu arrêtes je souhaiterais je
souhaiterais me présenter pour
continuer le travail mais renforcer la
dynamique et on en reparlera mais un peu
rajeunir les cadres et trouver des
nouveaux moyens de militer parce que les
républicains étaient un parti classique
conventionnel et c'est vrai que quand on
voit l'offre aujourd'hui en France il y
a des parties qui ont adopté des moyens
de militantisme beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus modernes et c'est ce que je veux
faire avec cette fédération que vous
l'avez dit Patrice qui est importante
qui est qui qui structure le territoire
parce que les républicains sont bien
présents dans les Yvelines beaucoup de
mairies beaucoup de mairies beaucoup de
conseils départementaux le département
exactement juste les législatives en
effet qui alors vous avez été député
mais
dernière législatives pas d'élus même
vous avez tous été éliminés ou dès le
premier tour je crois oui oui oui c'est
c'est le grand paradoxe des républicains
c'est qu'on est devenu un parti
territoire on est d'une partie d'élus
locaux
peut-être c'est également
les deux France politique que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire une France
nationale avec des gros partis l'extrême
droite extrême gauche au centre le
macronisme
nous bah forcément avec les résultats
qu'on a eu au présidentiel les deux
dernières présidentielles ça plombe un
peu aux et la Cinquième République elle
est elle est faite comme ça c'est-à-dire
que l'élection présidentielle c'est la
meilleure des élections
mais le reste c'est le terrain c'est le
local c'est les mairies les départements
les régions le Sénat donc
c'est vrai que les républicains sont
plutôt bien présents sur le terrain
c'est un parti
peut-être au fond de France une Front
national alors avec les macronistes les
mélanges
le pénis en gros et dans les Territoires
évidemment et l'air est très présent le
Parti socialiste maintient aussi par
rapport au 1,7% de Daniel Go
présidentiel c'est vrai qu'on retrouve
ce caractère un peu classique qu'on a
toujours connu droit de gauche dans les
territoires moi au niveau national
aujourd'hui au niveau national c'est un
peu la confusion la confusion des
segments politiques on sait plus qui est
qui est droite qui est de gauche on sait
pas ce que macronisme c'est enfin on
sait pas vraiment beaucoup de choses au
niveau national au niveau local on est
bien structuré c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
les extrêmes sont moins représentés au
niveau territorial le centre est
représenté la gauche est représentée la
droite volonté on revient à un courant
traditionnel de la 5ème République alors
il y a quand même au-delà de tout ça une
crise des partis politiques
traditionnels une crise même du
médétantisme politique vous le disiez on
milite différemment au milieu de moins
dans les réunions de Préaux comme on le
faisait autrefois
et des réseaux sociaux il y a les
internet enfin qui jouent beaucoup
est-ce que vous pensez que certains
disent un peu les partis politiques
c'est fini est-ce que vous pensez que
non on peut encore réactiver le
militantisme politique il se il se
recréer ces partis politiques le parti
politique commence n'a jamais été comme
en Allemagne par exemple avec le SPD ou
avec le la CD ou en plus lié à des
syndicats donc c'était c'était des
mammouths en France on n'a jamais eu
cette grande culture là part peut-être à
un moment donné le Parti communiste dans
les années 30 etc la droite n'a jamais
eu peut-être à l'époque du RPR on disait
le RP c'était le parti
des militants et l'UDF c'est parti des
élus voilà on se partageait un petit peu
avec un leader aujourd'hui le problème
c'est qu'il y a une crise du leadership
en France qui fait qu'au Parti
socialiste il y a pas de leader
aux républicains il y en a beaucoup avec
beaucoup de talents on a vu
Eric ce petit Laurent Wauquiez David
Lisnard
que les autres me pardonnent je vais pas
me faire des amis mais c'est vrai qu'on
a beaucoup de on a beaucoup de on a
beaucoup de leaders et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que parti
politique est en train de se recréer
c'est un peu l'objectif de nos élections
locales c'est que il va falloir passer
ce cap de la modernité lors de ses
élections internes sinon je le dis comme
je le pense et ça va être très compliqué
pour les républicains pourquoi d'abord
parce qu'il y a il y a ça bouge beaucoup
les réseaux sociaux bougent beaucoup je
pense qu'il faut faire des efforts nous
en matière de communication en matière
de de contenu en matière de vidéo de de
de enfin bref il nous manque beaucoup de
choses chez les républicains pour
communiquer il y a cette espèce de de
priorité qu'on a toujours donné au
terrain à l'élection
à la présence sur le sur les marchés ça
c'est vrai qu'il y avait quelqu'un sont
très fort très très fort mais c'est vrai
qu'on oublie communiquer il va falloir
s'occuper de ces nouvelles formes de
militantisme de la communication mais
également aussi de l'accueil des
nouveaux militants on ne fait pas grand
chose pour les militants qui viennent
nous voir et qui frappent à la porte
c'est quand même un geste
important d'aller voir un parti
politique surtout les républiques donc
vous êtes un homme de communication
c'est vrai que moi je portais du doigt
au fil des années parce que je suis
quand même vice-présent de la Fédération
je pointais du doigt en disant peut-être
qu'on peut mieux faire là-dessus on peut
mieux accueillir les militants on peut
mieux communiquer on peut on peut
peut-être créer de nouveaux événements
j'en ai créé un avant les vacances avec
avec la le Bureau Fédéral on a créé un
beau un beau buffet campagnard qui a
rassemblait plus de 200 personnes quand
même donc je pense qu'il faut reprendre
l'habitude et puis je je mets un bémol
quand même Patrice c'est que le covid
nous a nous a cassé les pattes et c'est
plus compliqué c'est plus compliqué mais
pas que nous à la culture les musées les
théâtres les cinémas c'est un peu la
même chose c'est très difficile de
sortir aujourd'hui et quand on sait
qu'une part des militants sont âgées
étagés donc c'est c'est compliqué
on a des jeunes
on est peut-être un peu plus faible sur
les sur les sur les cadres et on a des
personnes un peu plus un peu plus âgées
c'est un peu le profil politique des
parties sauf peut-être à la nups
également qui est parti à ces jeunes
voilà mais les parties traditionnelles
restent traditionnels voilà dans dans la
pyramide d'âge alors un mot encore sur
cette élection du 26 novembre donc vous
êtes deux candidats
Othman Nasro qui est candidat a été
votre supplément quand vous étiez à
l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce qu'il y a deux lignes politiques
ou
est-ce que c'est plus une question de
personnalité au fond non c'est c'est
Othman comme vous l'avez dit a été mon
suppléant à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons gagné ensemble
voilà on a essayé voir j'ai essayé de de
d'expliquer que peut-être que une
candidature unique sur une élection
interne
voilà bien sûr à jour
[Musique]
après cet effet disait c'était très
difficile pour les candidats LR
d'expliquer l'intérêt dans votre
d'opposition à l'extrême centrisme comme
l'extrémisme et c'est vrai que on s'est
demandé il y a deux circonscriptions qui
ont qui ont été gagné par les filles
parlait dupez c'est les deux
circonscriptions où il y avait des
sortants parce qu'en fait avec mon
collègue Michel Viallet qui lui était
élu à menthe et moi j'étais lu dans la
dans le septième nouvelle dans la 11e
11e
nous avons été élu dans des quartiers
populaires pourquoi pourquoi et c'est là
où on revient peut-être à l'élection
interne
Michel violet à menthe comme moi nous
sommes des élus un peu chevronnés on a
été maire
régionaux départementaux députés on a on
a cette connaissance du terrain on
connaît bien les Yvelines on y est
depuis des années des années
local l'ancrage du terrain a beaucoup
joué dans l'élection dans l'élection
législative je pense à lorsqu'on a été
élu ensuite
la circonception la 11e circonscient la
mienne elle prend comme on dit le vent
c'est à dire elle prend voilà
des élections présidentielles en fait
alors vous allez me dire non parce que
le Macron ayant gagné le président
Macron ayant gagné vous avez gagné
peut-être que la candidate aurait dû
être élu non parce que d'abord elle
était parachutée comme d'ailleurs le
président comme le candidat et les
filles trop trop
récemment parachuté donc elle a
peut-être pas eu le temps de prendre le
poulet terrain et puis il y a eu cette
espèce de de Mélenchon Premier ministre
et toute cette espèce de surcom d'elle
et fille qui a qui a été
influencé probablement la jeunesse et
c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça que
les deux circonscriptions populaires ont
basculé LFI je suis pas sûr que dans le
temps ces circonscriptions on en
reparlera je me trompe
mais est-ce que vous regrettez pas au
fond après faire de la politique c'est
savoir avec qui on est contre qui on est
est-ce que vous regrettez pas au fond
qui est pas eu d'alliance entre le
candidat macroniste et vous et les
candidats de LR contre par exemple
lauperce on me l'a proposé moi sur la
circonscription j'étais député sortant
j'ai été approché j'étais approché
les militants le savent j'étais approché
par par le pouvoir en place pour pouvoir
représenter ce pouvoir en place je je
sais pas comment j'aurais fait après
avoir combattu après avoir combattu en
marche et le gouvernement avoir porté
des sujets comme la sécurité et
l'immigration la politique pénitentiaire
me concernant etc dire du jour au
lendemain je viens avec vous on change
pas d'équipe lorsque le match a démarré
je vais pas jouer avec le PSG et puis le
à la mi-temps je vais jouer avec eux
c'est c'est pas possible ou alors en
tout cas je sais pas faire ou alors il
faudrait que j'apprenne alors s'il y a
des coachs qui sont spécialistes du
retournement de veste moi je suis
preneur mais
je sais pas faire
parce que mais parce que pour aller plus
dans le fond et plus sérieux il y a une
part du macronisme qui parle à la droite
oui absolument on parlera après pour les
présidentielles mais il y a une part du
macronisme moi je sais que beaucoup de
militants qui ont voté pour moi à la
mairie au département
moi j'avoue avoir et puis en plus il
faut comment dire il faut vouloir
changer de camp moi si vous voulez j'ai
coché les cases comme on dit j'étais
mère j'étais conseiller départemental
vice-présidente du département député
écoutez j'ai pas j'ai voilà j'ai coché
les cas c'est très content j'ai pas de
j'ai pas d'ambition effrénées voilà je
vais pas tuer père et mère pour pour
garder mon siège de député voilà j'ai je
suis resté fidèle à mes côtés voilà
autre forte présence avant de parler de
présent sur le territoire de LR il vient
d'y avoir les élections sédatoriales
j'ai remarché vient d'être réduit au
plateau comme on dit
à la présidence du Sénat
c'est pas une surprise mais dans les
Yvelines il y avait 5 sortants elle est
il y en a quatre hyper un siège et puis
il y a une surprise Martin lévrier qui
était le candidat Renaissance
reprend son poste et puis il y a une
surprise c'est celui de Ghislaine sonné
écolo candidate de la gauche qu'on avait
pas vu venir si je peux dire
oui c'est vrai mais alors d'abord
félicitations à Gérard à Gérard Larcher
pour pour son élection en plus il est
fait un très bon score beaucoup plus que
ce que représente sa propre majorité
donc ça veut dire qu'il a quand même
élargi il a quand même élargi son socle
quand même fort et puis c'est ta
République donc il faut aussi se
féliciter des victoires qui sont rares
mais il faut se féliciter de nos
victoires
alors c'est toujours l'histoire de la
bouteille à moitié vide ou la bouteille
à moitié pleine quand je compare avec
les autres départements avoir 4 4
sénateurs sur une même liste élue c'est
pas si je suis pas sûr qu'il y en a
beaucoup dans le dans l'Hexagone je ne
suis pas sûr
il pouvait y en avoir 6 comme il pouvait
y avoir 5 ou 4 ça s'est joué très très
peu de choses moi j'ai vécu la soirée la
soirée littorale j'ai vu chez les deux
autres sénateurs Martin lévrier et la
candidate
Ghislaine beaucoup beaucoup de stress et
d'appréhension et de et j'ai eu peur
parce que ça s'est joué à très peu de
choses vous savez le scrutin sénateur
est très compliqué je vais très
compliqué aussi
voilà il y a des calculs des éditions
des soustractions c'est très compliqué
donc ça peut se jouer la liste de Gérard
chi aurait pu faire 6 comme 5 comme 4 à
quelques voies près ça s'est joué à 4
parce que la candidat socialiste a
pardon l'expression à ramasser plusieurs
voies à la fin qui fait que qui fait
qu'elle a été elle a été élue mais
quatre sénateurs sur 6 plutôt bien c'est
plutôt même très bien on en paiera c'est
vrai on en paiera parce que la dernière
fois c'était un autre contexte mais
franchement c'est plutôt très
satisfaisant pour notre famille
politique alors les sénateurs donc
Sophie prima il y a
Michel Granier et Michel Losier voilà
vous avez raison il était 3e
sur la liste qui était en l'ancien maire
de Montigny puis quitter
sortant
c'est important quand même qui est
justement on a vu l'élection de
marché
[Musique]
on voit bien que
contrairement ce qu'on aurait pu penser
en 2017 avec le nouveau monde et
l'ancien monde que le Sénat allait
perdre du pouvoir au contraire il a un
pouvoir de plus en plus important et
pour probablement peut-être que la
présidence de Gérard Larcher a apporté
aussi cette c'est très juste c'est très
juste mais je pense que c'est dû à
plusieurs facteurs dont un en
particulier c'est de la recentrerisation
politique du macronisme c'est la
verticalité de de Manuela Macron qui a
donné j'ai envie de dire un peu plus
d'espace et de visibilité et de
lisibilité au Sénat qui est l'assemblée
des communes c'est-à-dire que le Sénat
représente aujourd'hui un contre-pouvoir
territorial voilà
grosso modo c'est-à-dire que le Sénat
aujourd'hui c'est l'assemblée des
territoires comme un contre-pouvoir à la
verticalité du pouvoir du macronisme
aujourd'hui et cette ouverture permet
aujourd'hui de mieux connaître les
Sénats et de mieux connaître nos
sénateurs qui sont pas forcément les
personnes les plus les plus connues
comme les mers etc mais qui font un
travail de terrain parce que ils
représentent les communes il représente
les territoires en France donc c'est
important cette espèce de grand conseil
des communes c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
une bonne chose surtout dans ce contexte
de recentralisation
si on parle de politique qu'est-ce que
vous êtes de ceux qui pensent que au
fond le macronisme aura été une
parenthèse et que la vraie coupure
droite goût enfin la vraie coupure c'est
la coupure droite-gauche et qu'elle va
réapparaître
il y a toujours eu sous la Cinquième
République une une obsession à sortir de
la bipolarité politique droite gauche on
a toujours cru ça deux Français sur
trois c'était le slogan
et ça a toujours été la grande volonté
de créer une troisième force qui a qui
est apparue d'un même sous la Quatrième
République mais qui qui est un peu
baissé sous la 5e il y a toujours eu
cette volonté là le macronisme
représente deux choses la crise des
partis politiques traditionnels sur
lequel il a surfé sur que le Président
de la République a surfait et cette
volonté de créer une troisième voie
jusqu'à maintenant je suis citoyen de
formation donc je je
j'analyse le passé jusqu'à maintenant ça
n'a pas marché on est toujours revenu à
cette espèce de
bipolarité du
passé
je suis pas sûr qu'on revienne parce
qu'il y a une troisième force qui est
apparue oui très importante voir une
quatrième c'est l'extrême droite les
sangliers
de reprise au second tour des des
présidentielles et un maillage
territorial
donc je pense que le le paysage
politique français est fragmenté
aujourd'hui
alors justement vous avez été député il
y a beaucoup de choses qui se passent à
l'Assemblée il y a beaucoup de 49-3
sur le sur le budget on sait comme les
LR ne voteront pas la motion de censure
sur l'immigration c'est
un peu plus discuté est-ce que si vous
étiez député est-ce que vous iriez
jusqu'à une motion de censure ou est-ce
que vous dites que au fond
c'est compliqué j'avoue que j'ai
j'aurais dû j'ai dû j'aurais du mal à me
positionner aujourd'hui comme comme
député il faut savoir une chose c'est
que le 49-3 à l'origine c'était un outil
de modération parce qu'en fait lorsque
la Cinquième République a été créée
Michel Debré a essayé de créer des
moyens de tempérer le pouvoir absolu
entre guillemets c'est à dire le pouvoir
présidentiel par plusieurs outils
parlementaires le 49-3 étant l'un des
l'un des outils pour pour essayer un
petit peu de faire passer des lois
parlementaires on va dire et de donner
du pouvoir au Parlement bon on en est
plus là on en est plus là on est plus
dans cet espèce de début de la cinquième
République où il y avait un président
très très fort et un parlement qui était
encore un peu faiblard au début
maintenant faut-il voter la motion de
censure des carreaux de froid qui est
devenu la norme on n'a jamais vu ça
on n'a jamais connu ça on n'a pas connu
ça du tout sous Sarkozy mais là on on
revient à cette
majorité absolue parce qu'il y a une
majorité on l'a connu sous Hollande avec
une majorité absolue c'est vrai
mais là c'est un peu plus logique
puisqu'il n'y a pas de majorité il y a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
moi je c'est difficile la motion de
censure parce que
soit on expose ces convictions et on va
jusqu'au bout soit on essaye de faire
passer des sujets qui sont nécessaires à
la France c'est le sujet moi je suis
plutôt je suis plutôt je ne suis plus à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est très facile
de lire un plateau je serai un conseil
plutôt à un moment donné de censurer le
gouvernement lorsque notre lorsque les
sujets sont clivants très importants sur
l'immigration c'est un sujet important
si la majorité a besoin des LR pour
faire passer des lois nécessaires à la
République c'est un c'est c'est
bien
sur le budget
d'abord parce que vous défendez
vous-même des amendements dans le budget
vous allez pas vous auto censurer bon
sauf que c'est le gouverne enfin voilà
c'est la position du gouvernement donc
on pense que sur le sujet qui qui marque
la droite la sécurité l'immigration là
il y a je pense qu'il y a une réflexion
à avoir sur la motion de censure donc
oui c'est pas c'est pas impossible dans
ce cas euh Emmanuel Macron a dit très
clairement il y aura des solutions
est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas un
risque que prendrait les députés sortant
LR de revenir vers les électeurs
aujourd'hui c'est ça risque pour tout le
monde parce que alors les premiers les
premiers c'est la majorité c'est les
députés Renaissance eux sont vraiment
grand nombre on peut penser qu'il y
aurait qui aurait encore et juste de
députés
les députés du peste sont également et
les filles sont également contenus
mais on revient à la pagaille qui a
toujours été euh voilà entre trots et
stagnagna entre PC et gauchistes on a
toujours eu cette cette bagarre sur les
divisions de la dupes qui voilà donc
personne n'est gagnant dans une
dissolution voilà maintenant ça
appartient au président de la République
ça je sais pas si s'il arrivera
dissoudre je sais pas c'est après une
notion de censure qu'est-ce qui peut
faire le gouvernement démissionne non
non
vis-à-vis des députés alors justement
vous parler de l'immigration il y a une
chose qu'on
[Musique]
qui peut-être divise un peu la droite LR
enfin
on a du mal à comprendre c'est le
positionnement vis-à-vis du
rassemblement national il y a une grande
théorie qui est celle de Chirac a pas de
compromission avec avec l'extrême droite
on voit
par exemple sur le projet migration il
est pas très très loin par exemple du
projet de RN du RN
certains disaient qu'il y aurait
peut-être une scission justement entre
les les LR qui resteraient
dans l'histoire de de LR dans la
tradition de l'ADN de LR pas de
composition puis certains qui voudraient
une alliance avec la droite et droite
comme on peut le voir dans certains pays
européens quel est votre position
là-dessus
l'immigration est une folie politique
française c'est-à-dire que si vous n'en
parlez pas vous on vous le reproche dans
30 ans en disant vous n'avez pas été
vous n'avez pas été là au moment on vous
reproche même on me le reproche on nous
le reproche de ne pas avoir appliqué le
fameux programme RP rudf de la fin des
années 80 sur l'immigration qui était
maintenant comme par hasard très très
bien rédigé et très bien fait et si vous
en parlez vous faites le jeu du Front
national donc que faire voilà soit on en
parle parce que nous sommes à partir
responsable et nous en avons parlé dans
le passé mais à l'époque quand on en
parlait on était très chaud que faire
une vraie folie c'est-à-dire que si vous
avez des sujets qui ressemblent à la
macronie enfin qui pas qui ressemble
mais qui mais qui
dont vous êtes proche du gouvernement ou
si vous avez des sujets proches de
l'extrême droite vous êtes coincé donc à
un moment donné il faut avoir la liberté
de parler de ce qu'on a envie de parler
voilà de ce dont on a envie de parler
l'immigration est un sujet français qui
est aujourd'hui transversal il y a 10
ans ne pouvait pas en parler il y avait
une espèce de bien pensé de gauche qui
nous interdisait de parler de migration
voilà le résultat aujourd'hui c'était
aujourd'hui
l'immigration est un vrai une vraie
problématique française qu'on aurait pu
régler si on avait laissé la droite
plutôt que passionnel d'ailleurs
exactement c'est pour ça que je parle de
folie politique c'est
vrai que vous avez raison ça c'est pas
c'est pas voilà c'est pas nos politiques
qui va changer le système
d'immigration en France c'est un système
en entier qu'il faut changer
c'est-à-dire que l'État les préfectures
qui sont responsables de l'entrée et de
l'intégration des populations étrangères
en France via plusieurs canaux les
logements sociaux etc etc c'est pas un
homme politique qui va changer tout ça
si on peut en parler en effet de manière
technique et de régler pour ce problème
là ce serait quand même pas mal mais à
l'époque on nous entendait pas mais je
reviens alors sur la question politique
est-ce que vous êtes de ceux chez les LR
qui disent jamais d'accord avec avec le
RN ou est-ce que et puis il y a une
autre tendance qui dit pourquoi pas
faire un grand mouvement de droite et de
mais vous savez quand on dit quand on
dit pourquoi pas faire un grand
mouvement de droite dans ces cas-là il
faut être les plus forts dans l'alliance
oui parce que sinon
vous vous retrouvez comme le Parti
socialiste aujourd'hui avec la nups donc
n'en parlons pas
je pense que la terre est de l'air c'est
de retrouver le socle de droite et de
retrouver la le segment droite qui est
toujours été le nôtre et donc de
récupérer ce que une partie de la
macronie a perdu à nos appels nous a
fait perdre quoi voilà c'est ça c'est
déjà récupéré notre cercle de droite
mais quand Nicolas Sarkozy dit celui qui
gagnera en 2027 sera celui qui arrivera
à faire l'alliance entre Zemmour
c'est étonnant
je vous présente la République
aujourd'hui il nous demande de regarder
à notre droite c'est bizarre quand même
c'est un peu je vois pas comment on peut
faire l'alliance entre les deux je sais
pas très honnêtement je suis un peu
étonné de la de la voilà c'est de de
cette intervention de l'ancien président
alors il y a évidemment les élections
présidentielles qui se préparent Laurent
Wauquiez qui est le candidat d'Éric
Ciotti puisque
qui préside le LR voilà il est sorti du
bois qu'on dit on dirait qu'il était
qu'il était prêt
comment ça va se passer justement à
votre avis la présidence c'est compliqué
à dire je vous dis pas demande pas qui
sera élu en 2027 mais du côté de la
droite parce que il y a un effet le
robot qui mais il y a
comme Édouard Philippe comme Gérald
Darmanin peut-être comme Bruno Le Maire
qui viennent aussi de chez vous et qui
peuvent être aussi candidats voyons on
revient la mer des à la mer des
batailles on parlait totalement de la
Cinquième République la mère des
batailles c'était les présidentielles on
revient toujours toujours sur cette
question des présidentielles on est à 3
ans des présidentielles c'est-à-dire qui
en 2017 lorsque Emmanuel Macron a été en
2014 donc trois ans avant personne ne
connaissait Emmanuel Macron donc qui va
connaître le candidat qui sera notre
candidat ou la candidat de la droite en
2027 voilà donc il y a plusieurs
candidats qui sont sur le ligne de
départ c'est vrai à l'intérieur même de
notre partie des gens
il y a Aurélien
Xavier Bertrand il y a Laurent Wauquiez
dont on a parlé et probablement d'autres
je n'en sais rien et puis il y en a
d'autres à la périphérie des
républicains comme Gérald Darmanin Bruno
Le Maire ou Édouard Philippe voilà ça
c'est
la photo actuelle de des candidatures de
2027 je suis pas sûr que ça sera qu'on
aura ça à la fin oui et on voit
généralement que les les favoris qui
sont favoris deux ou trois ans avant on
y arrive exactement il faut jamais en
parler
mais est-ce que vous pensez il y a une
enquête de des enquêtes de cevipov qui
montre ça qui est une droiteisation de
la France est-ce que vous pensez que
l'élection va se jouer justement à
droite
oui il y a une droitisation des
thématiques en France aujourd'hui ça
c'est vrai avec l'immigration mais avec
aussi
le social et toutes ces questions là
mais pas que je pense pas d'abord y
aller la thématique de d'environnement
environnemental qui sont qui sont
importants donc je suis pas sûr que
moi je suis su d'une d'une génération
politique on disait l'élection
présidentielle se gagne au centre il
faut absolument voilà il faut pouvoir
rassembler à un moment Nicolas Sarkozy a
fait une campagne présidentielle où il a
gagné à droite très à droite oui voilà
et encore que la première présidentielle
ici aussi j'aurais il fait venir
Glucksman il a convoqué il a convoqué
toutes les 2e à mon avis mais beaucoup
et il a perdu il a perdu il a perdu
aujourd'hui avec le le la puissance que
représente le rassemblement national je
ne suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
droit ils ont notre campagne on préfère
pas l'original à la commission c'est
toujours le problème c'est toujours
c'est toujours le je pense qu'on a une
vraie légitimité on a une vraie image
qui est de droite sur certains sujets
plus modérés sur d'autres l'Europe le
budget etc et je pense qu'il y a une
place pour une droite responsable une
droite à l'aise dans ses baskets pas
forcément extrémistes pas forcément
mollassonne il y a une vraie droite qui
incarne le pays depuis des siècles et
des décennies et je pense qu'il faut
revenir à cette droite là justement
peut-être une des
erreurs je sais pas de la campagne de
Valérie Pécresse juger aujourd'hui mais
c'est peut-être d'avoir
surestimé le danger Zemmour et d'avoir
été un peu de ce côté là d'avoir que ton
papa qui ne correspondait pas forcément
à sa personnalité d'ailleurs c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai en plus
le score est très très décevant puisque
on a même pas on n'a même pas franchi
les 5%, je pense qu'elle a aussi subi le
nouveau paysage politique français
deux parties à sa droite un parti massif
au centre son espace son espace très
très réduit ça a été difficile de de
faire campagne dans ces conditions
parler de Laurent Wauquiez vous parlez
des impératifs écologiques qui vont se
le retrait du du zan qu'il a annoncé de
sa région Rhône-Alpes
pour ceux que c'est un bon signe ou pas
je sais pas je sais pas en tout cas
c'est un bon président de Région parce
qu'il est très très
reconnu comme un vrai président de
région il a aussi dans sa région comme
dans le Nord et comment en Île-de-France
d'ailleurs des écolos un peu
extrémistes radicaux un peu fou fou qui
fait que l'écologie la plus responsable
et l'écologie la plus la plus concrète
c'est celle que porte les élus de droite
du centre droit et du centre gauche
c'est-à-dire une écologie responsable de
psychologie d'extrême gauche pas une
écologie punity idéologique
peut-être le message qu'il a voulu faire
passer
un mot encore sur votre candidature à la
présidence de la fédération donc selon
le 5 octobre mais c'est pas c'est pas un
meeting public
toujours dit une chose c'est que je ne
lançais pas ma campagne pendant les
sénatoriales je pense qu'il faut avoir
ce prix de responsabilité la priorité
c'était de mobiliser les grands
électeurs pour faire gagner la liste de
Gérard Larcher c'est le cas on a gagné
donc maintenant l'objectif c'est de
lancer ma compagne faire deux choses en
même temps je n'y crois pas donc là
maintenant je lance pas campagne le 5 à
Versailles on sera très nombreux il y
aura l'archer et puis à Bédié Sophie
primat il y aura beaucoup d'élus
beaucoup de mères beaucoup
tous ceux qui me soutiennent beaucoup de
délégués de circonscription comme on dit
beaucoup de mer beaucoup de conseillers
départementaux donc ça ça va être ça va
être le grand moment moi je pars d'un
principe très rapidement même si on en a
déjà parlé que il faut à la fois du
renouvellement comme je l'ai dit mais
aussi de l'expérience voilà j'ai fait
basculer une ville j'ai fait parce que
circonscription j'ai fait basculer un
canton je pense que cette cette
expérience de terrain est utile pour les
républicains aujourd'hui et puis
également il faut aussi ce que j'ai dit
renouveler de fond en comble la maison
pas dit qu'elle était en ruine mais elle
elle portait une histoire maintenant je
pense qu'il faut maintenant rien à venir
et porter cet avenir là maintenant en
matière de communication en matière de
militantisme et en matière de contenu
aussi avec des thématiques importantes
comme l'environnement que l'on a
tendance de temps en temps à oublier on
va pour terminer on va faire un petit
jeu allez je vais vous montrer vous
allez voir des photos et puis vous allez
choisir entre les voilà le personnalité
qui sont là on commence allez on y va
vous fâcher avec des
je pense que ça tout ça est derrière
nous je pense tout ça est derrière nous
ce sont de deux personnes d'ailleurs qui
ont fait l'histoire des Yvelines
fédération députés ministres
voilà donc ce sont deux deux
personnalités qui qui compte énormément
avec Gérard Larcher bien sûr dans le
département que ceux qui veulent
entretenir la petite la petite guéguerre
bon on les laisse à leur petite
guéguerre picrocoli quoi justement hier
enfin il de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
et Pierre medie était là et il y a eu
des discours où il disait on peut être
on peut être mère et député
je pense que le la question du cumul des
mandat va probablement revenir vous êtes
je serai pour un pour le cumulité mais
on va limiter dans les détails je pense
que le nom qui me demandes des mandats
c'était une question d'air du temps on a
voulu faire plaisir un peu à l'heure du
temps en disant on va faire du
renouvellement on n'a pas on a fait
aucun renouvellement parce qu'on s'est
retrouvé avec des députés à l'Assemblée
nationale et je l'ai connu à l'Assemblée
nationale sans ancrage local on les
voyait un peu batailler pour s'intégrer
dans leur propre territoire dans leur
propre territoire deuxièmement je pense
qu'on peut facilement aujourd'hui alors
je suis j'étais député conseil
départemental je ne peux pas être député
et même c'est quand même quelque chose
un peu incroyable alors qu'on limite le
nombre d'habitants d'une mairie parce
qu'on est qu'au bout de 5000 ou 200 000
habitants de grande ville mais on ne
favorise pas le renouvellement en
lâchant l'un ou l'autre nous favorise
rien puisqu'on met quelqu'un de son
équipe à la tête de la mairie ou voilà
donc
c'est un peu une hypocrisie un peu un
peu l'air du temps je suis pour le le
retour
est une tradition républicaine
d'ailleurs on continue avec On y va
j'ai plus la photo je me souviens plus
du 3e mais
David David
listin c'est que les territoires c'est
un grand Girondins je pense un grand
Girondins décentralisateur dont on aura
probablement énormément besoin dans
cette campagne de millions de sexe vous
avez Bertrand et Laurent Wauquiez sont
des grands présidents de région ce sont
des des des ce que j'appelle moi les
notablabilités politiques ce sont des
gens qui sont ancrés dans les dans leur
territoire ce sont des des des d'anciens
ministres d'anciennes je pense qu'on a
la chance aux républicain d'avoir ces
trois là vous allez me dire je fais une
réponse de Normand mais très honnêtement
choisir entre l'un ou l'autre c'est un
peu c'est un peu doute c'est un peu
difficile mais je mettrai quand même
l'originalité de d'aller présente
justement ces territoires vous voyez je
savais pas que vous allez faire ce jeu
là je parlais tout à l'heure de la
décentralisation et je pense que c'est
important autre photo
il y a des qualités aujourd'hui dans le
rassemblement national il faut être
honnête le renouvellement des cadres des
députés jeunes un ancrage finalement
dans les territoires pour un particulier
qui n'était pas très bien bien ancré je
pense que Marine Le Pen a raté ces deux
débats politiques donc elle n'a pas
encore pris la mesure du poste Emmanuel
Macron c'est le en même temps que moi je
ne voulais pas j'en veux pas voilà autre
photo
Mélenchon Roussel moi je suis sûr
même si je ne suis pas du tout pas du
tout communiste et loin de là et je l'ai
même combattu dans ma jeunesse je pense
que Fabien Roussel incarne quand même
une idée une certaine idée de la
République qui n'est pas la mienne qui
n'est pas la mienne mais il incarne il
vient on l'oublie un peu souvent parce
qu'on on demande toujours à des gens
d'extrême droite de se justifier par
rapport au rassemblement national
j'aimerais qu'on justifie aussi des élus
qui viennent du Parti communiste qui
était un parti stalinien et qui a été un
parti qui a joué contre la République à
une époque pour les soviets contre la
République donc j'oublie pas ça mais à
choisir entre les deux je préfère la
force des convictions sympathiques d'un
Roussel que
celui qui va battre le système et qui
installe le chaos dans notre pays parce
que les violences sont aussi suscitées
par un certain discours pas le discours
de Rousset le discours de Mélenchon lui
on dit que c'est c'est l'homme préféré
de gauche préféré des Français mais
c'est aussi l'homme de gauche préféré de
la droite oui c'est possible vous disais
ça de regards les unes photos
ou Sandrine Rousseau allez priorité à
notre sénatrice départementale s'en
enverrai Rousseau c'est un animal
médiatique
probablement des problèmes de
reconnaissance parce que elle parle de
tout et de rien en même temps que je
préfère la force du terrain on continue
même si j'adore Mick Jagger j'ai adoré
le voir parler a Gérard Larcher
les disques que j'ai à la maison bien
sûr les CD
Beatles
McCartney parce que c'est l'un des plus
le plus grand probablement compositeur
de pop music qui a laissé une trace
incroyable et qui influençait tous les
grands groupes vous interrogez n'importe
qui mais Giger compris il serait faire
tout ça au Beatles
on continue
alors là j'étais un peu plus jeune à
gauche est-ce que c'est très jeune mère
ou député qu'est-ce qui vous a plu le
plus mais je pense merde parce que on
décide on décide dép j'ai adoré c'était
un honneur j'ai travaillé sur des sujets
incroyables j'ai rencontré des gens
extraordinaires j'ai fait partie des
plus belles commissions de la République
j'étais président de la commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur les prisons
j'ai voyagé j'ai travaillé sur le
terrain j'ai représenté ma 11e
circonscription c'est un très très beau
travail presque intellectuel j'ai envie
de dire mais mère c'est d'abord c'est
d'abord un plaisir d'être reconnu dans
sa propre ville qu'on adore que j'adore
et si les résultats ce qu'on fait et on
voit les résultats de ce qu'on fait la
ville a totalement changé avec le mandat
que j'ai fait et c'est vrai que c'est le
l'échelon de la proximité les choses à
la décision elle est de dernière photo
mais je prendrai les deux hein
ils sont tous les deux présidents
[Musique]